the David Pakman show subreddit, a top destination
for viewers and listeners of the show to respectfully
discuss political ideas, uh, at David pakman.com/reddit
has surpassed 13,000 subscribers. One of the
largest progressive media subreddits, uh,
period. I don't think I have to qualify it
in any further way. Uh, interesting post from
a recent interview I did. I was recently interviewed
on an interesting a show called startups hosted
by entrepreneur Dan Saltman and streamer Steven
Destiny Banal.
And we talked about the future of the David
Pakman show on twitch. And uh, yes, I mean
we're not for people who are worried that
we're moving over to twitch and abandoning
anything. We are not, we're not abandoning
youtube, we're not abandoning the podcast.
We're still as committed as ever to those
platforms. But my view is always diversify
platforms and revenue streams in order to
reduce reliance on any particular one. Um,
would have surfaced well during apocalypse
2017. So we are increasingly publishing more
and streaming more on twitch and uh, make
sure you're following me there at twitch.tv/david
Pakman. If you have Amazon prime, you can
subscribe for free with twitch prime. It's
a paid subscription for us, but it costs you
nothing. Someone also noticing and putting
together a funny meme that Sam Harris started
following me on Twitter. That's true. I have
no idea why.
I've had no contact with Sam about it. I don't
know, um, anything about it other than I noticed
Sam Harris is now following me on Twitter
and maybe something will at some point come
of it. And then also increasingly there are
posts and memes and images about people calling
in during live calls. And I don't pick up
on them. Here's one called when David doesn't
choose your call, this is w I, I don't really
know how to deal with this. When we take live
calls now, we often get 70, 80, or even sometimes
close to a a hundred people that are holding
at once. And usually I take, you know, 10
to 12 calls at a time. I don't really know
what can do in terms of making it. So a lot
of people don't sit on hold and are never
able to get on. People who have had the idea
of capping the, um, uh, capping the phone
line queue at 20 people, for example.
But the problem is there's a lot of really
frequent callers and I try to go to New People.
We keep notes about like when did I last pick
up on someone and if I picked up on someone
three days prior and I have 50 other people
who I've never talked to, I'm going to prioritize
the people I've never talked to just to make
sure that we're not always talking to the
same people. So limiting the cue to 20 is
problematic because 20 people that regularly
call might be in the queue, so I don't know
how to deal with that. I understand the frustration
of people not being able to get on a, but
it is something that we're working on ideas
as always. Very very much welcome. Make sure
you are subscribed to the subreddit. It's
a great place to suggest ideas for the show,
chat with other viewers and listeners.
David pakman.com/r e d d I t